There are many things in this world that we
do not, and perhaps cannot, understand.
The SCP Foundation dedicates itself to researching
and containing these things, but even they
occasionally encounter something that defies
any kind of true understanding.
The unknown is terrifying to the average person,
but for an organization that specializes in
knowing the unknowable, a mystery that refuses
to be understood can be downright nightmarish.
A Foundation expedition team lost contact
with their command while on a mission in the
Northern Ural mountains of Russia.
After six hours of silence, radio contact
was reestablished, though video feed continued
to be disabled.
A lone agent, Dr. Felsenstein, called out
desperately over the radio waves, begging
for someone, anyone, to answer him.
Command responded, requesting a status update
on the rest of his crew.
At first, they were met only with the wet,
hollow sound of Felsenstein weeping.
Finally, he explained that they were all dead,
and he was the only man left standing.
“Something got him,” he said, of fellow
agent Myers.
“It was long…slippery.
I saw a grown man pulled into a tiny hole.”
He began to hyperventilate, his descriptions
becoming less and less coherent.
Command offered to send reinforcements to
collect the survivor, but he begged them not
to.
He was beyond saving at this point, describing
himself as “nothing but a walking corpse.”
After slipping into a crevice, Felsenstein
had broken his ankle and torn a hole in his
hazmat suit.
Command honored his insistence that no reinforcements
be sent in, but encouraged him to try and
pull himself back to the surface and retrieve
additional data.
Even if he was doomed, he could still provide
valuable information on the threat he encountered.
When Felsenstein attempted to free himself
from the crevice, he slipped deeper into the
crack in the ground.
Pushing through his fear of being crushed
to death, he tried again.
Fighting against the burning of the toxic
air in his lungs and the straining of his
muscles, he finally pulled himself to freedom.
Then, he took in his surroundings.
He was at the edge of a chasm, so deep he
could not see the bottom.
He posited that he was somewhere underneath
or inside of a mountain.
There was a putrid smell in the air, burning
his eyes, his skin, everything.
Command told him to remain calm, still hoping
for the possibility of a rescue.
Meanwhile, on their end, hostile forces were
closing in and forcing them to evacuate.
They asked Felsenstein to continue describing
his surroundings, so that his account might
be recorded for the archives.
They would attempt to come back with reinforcements
when it was safe for them to do so.
As Felsenstein made it deeper into the chasm,
he was engulfed in a thick yellow fog.
Through the haze, he could make out thousands
of eggs, and piles of meat being devoured
by small creatures with the bodies of grubs
and the faces of human infants.
The creatures did not respond to his presence,
either unaware of him or too consumed with
their feeding to care.
As he passed the creatures, he spotted a massive
black temple with architecture like nothing
he had seen before, all polished and sharp
with angles that hurt his eyes to look at.
As he stopped to take a better look, he realized
he was still moving somehow, without moving
his feet.
He was being dragged by something, tendrils
wrapped around his legs and pulling him along
against his will, leaving a trail of his blood
behind.
As he was dragged, dozens of what seemed like
humans watched him.
The final words recorded on the audio transcript
were the most troubling of all.
Felsenstein saw what he described as an “angel”
with a thousand wings.
The angel pulled him into her embrace, clutching
him to her breast…and the connection was
lost.
Dr. Felsenstein was never seen again.
His colleagues’ bodies were never recovered.
The entire team of men was lost forever, inside
the incomprehensible hellhole known as SCP-2133.
SCP-2133 is an unnamed village in the Northern
Ural mountains in Eastern Europe, with an
estimated population of around fifty people.
The village is considered dangerous to enter
without proper hazmat gear, due to the presence
of a wide variety of microbial pathogens within
its limits, including those which cause leprosy,
pneumonic, septicemic, and bubonic plagues,
typhoid fever, influenza, cholera, and smallpox.
A veritable hypochondriac’s worst nightmare.
In spite of this cocktail of diseases in which
they live, the residents of 2133 seem to be
resistant to the negative effects of infection.
Of course, they experience physical symptoms,
to the point of visible disfigurement or disability,
but they do not die at a rate consistent with
the sheer volume of deadly pathogens present
in their town.
The people of SCP-2133 do not leave it.
The Foundation cannot fully determine whether
they cannot leave, or simply choose not to,
but whatever the case may be they stay within
the limits of their village.
Their relative resistance to disease, small
population, and refusal to leave the boundaries
of their village are all unusual, but that
is far from the most unusual thing about the
population of SCP-2133.
The people of the village age and die, yes,
but they do not stay dead.
They engage in what can only be described
as some kind of reincarnation.
When a resident of the village dies, they
are placed in the field, where they quickly
decay.
On the night of the first new moon, a newborn
infant is pulled from the soil where the decaying
body once lay.
The reborn version of each person looks like
their previous self, and carries all of the
memories they had in their previous life.
The Foundation performed extensive soil tests
on the field where this curious rebirth takes
place, and found that the soil there contains
high levels of embryonic fluid.
Beyond the presence of this fluid in the earth,
it is unknown how exactly this reincarnation
process works.
The residents of the village, known as SCP-2133-1,
speak an old Russian dialect and occasionally
agree to be interviewed by Foundation staff
fluent in this dialect.
Though they will sit for interviews and chat
with Foundation personnel, they are secretive
about their lives, their history, and the
culture of their little village.
The first resident to be successfully interviewed
was an elderly man named Aristarkh, who was
missing his left arm and had necrosis on most
of his visible skin.
The interview was conducted by Dr. Judith
Low, one of the head researchers on the case.
She asked the man how far back he was able
to remember, and he recounted a time of “Tsars
and Khans.”
When Dr. Low pressed the man about the rebirth
that his people practice, he responded that
it was “The Church of the Red Harvest.
We serve until the end.
That is the terms of our agreement.”
Dr. Low asked him why he, and the rest of
his people, would continue to live their lives
this way when it causes them such obvious
suffering.
He explained, simply: “There is no choice.
The land calls.
We answer.”
She continued to push the issue, inquiring
about how this all began so many years ago.
He explained that a priestess came to the
village many lifetimes ago.
She offered the people paradise, in exchange
for their servitude.
However, as the years passed, the people became
more and more exhausted.
They feared that they had failed somehow,
and were being punished.
Aristarkh became visibly upset at this point
in the interview, but continued to insist:
“The Church of the Red Harvest is truth.
There is no other.”
The second interview was conducted again by
Dr. Judith Low, who spoke with Anya, a young
girl who appeared to be between the ages of
six and eight.
Low greeted the girl, and attempted to ask
her first question, but Anya simply said:
“You don’t belong here.
Leave.”
Low brushed this off, and offered the girl
medical assistance, but was rebuffed again:
“You are not of the covenant.
You will never understand.”
Dr. Low asked Anya to elaborate on the nature
of this covenant, and her explanation was
similar to that of the previous interviewee.
There was an agreement made, a long time ago,
and now the people of the village would serve
until the end of time.
Again, she insisted that the Foundation should
leave, and did not belong in the town.
Finally, irritated with the questions, Anya
had only this to say about the church: “The
church was here long before the village.
A church of stone beneath the earth.
It is sacred.
A church of wood was built atop it, for the
heresy of the cross - before we embraced the
true faith.
The Karcist Alka will enlighten you.
You are only alive because she has chosen
to let you live.”
Hearing the word Karcist probably gives you
some indication as to what’s really going
on here - If the disease, corruption, and
mutation of the flesh didn’t give you enough
of a clue.
This horror is Sarkic through and through.
Dr. Low’s final question was a seemingly
easy one: does the village have a name?
As soon as the words left Dr. Low’s lips,
Anya began to vomit up a thick black substance,
ending the interview.
Instances of SCP-2133-1 are largely apathetic
toward Foundation agents, unless they get
in the way of their routine.
The agents are allowed to go inside of any
buildings in the village, with one notable
exception: the Church of the Red Harvest.
Any attempts to learn more about the church
or enter its walls are met with refusal to
explain, or, in some cases, outright hostility.
Though the villagers are largely peaceful
toward the Foundation, they are not the only
entity living in SCP-2133.
Throughout the village, there are instances
of something known as SCP-2133-2.
These organic structures, which have the appearance
of dark red tentacles, display overt hostility
toward outsiders and will attack any that
get too close.
They are especially aggressive to any outsiders
that attempt to enter the church.
Tissue samples were taken from the tentacles
for observation, and they were found, horrifyingly
enough, to genetically resemble tissue samples
from humans.
After the interview with Anya, the Foundation
research team determined that entering the
church was of the utmost importance.
Mobile Task Force Beta-7 was dispatched for
this mission, and, after the residents of
the town were restrained, a team of twelve
operatives was sent in.
They were armed with radios, video recorders,
hazmat suits, and air tanks.
As they attempted to enter the church, the
tentacles attacked, but were subdued with
flamethrowers.
Apparently, like most living things, they
are not immune to fire.
Inside the church, the research team found
small idols crafted from bone and leather,
and a few others made from tumors, hanging
from iron hooks on the ceiling.
At the building’s center was an entrance
to a system of caves and caverns beneath the
village, stretching beyond its borders into
the mountains.
Several previously unseen organisms, designated
only as SCP-2133-3, were discovered inside.
One was terminated, and taken back to the
Foundation for an autopsy.
The creature was humanoid in nature, with
swollen organs and flesh, and an overgrowth
of bone and fatty tissue.
After the autopsy, the team of operatives
refreshed their air tanks and headed back
into the village to continue their research.
About fifty minutes into their expedition,
all contact was lost out of nowhere.
Six hours later, Dr. Felsenstein would make
his infamous radio contact, and the nightmare
would unfold from there.
Currently, SCP-2133 is easily contained.
A security perimeter is maintained at a ten-kilometer
radius around the town, preventing any civilians
from making their way inside.
There are guards positioned along the perimeter,
under the guise of a Russian military base.
In spite of the horrifying nature of SCP-2133,
the villagers do not seem to pose an immediate
threat to anyone.
They simply want to be left alone, to till
the fields and attend their church, in an
endless cycle of winters and summers as they
wait for the end to come.
As they hope that finally, their agreement
will be honored, and they will find peace.
Now go check out “SCP-096 - The Shy Guy”
and “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor Captured”
for more horrifying humanoid SCPs.